hi everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today we are talking about
cyberpunk previews now honestly i would
have made this video months ago but
i hoped somebody else would um but it
kind of seems like that isn't happening
so here i
am i basically think there is a pretty
significant disservice that i realize
has been going on in the way that this
kind of thing has been covered
um both from games media and from the
way that i've seen a lot of youtubers
talk about it as well
and i think these people are setting
their audiences up to fail and i think
that i did that as well
um and this will happen again now
the reason i say i didn't want to make
this video is because i don't feel like
i'm the right person to make this video
because
uh as i have said literally every time i
have ever spoken about
cyberpunk this but first
a disclosure i'm just gonna make it
every time i ever talk about this game
just owning the fact that i'm very
biased where this is concerned i am
super biased where this game is
concerned i'm just owning that off the
jump i am
in the game so extremely biased where
it's concerned don't buy it because i
like it
i voice a very minor npc in the game and
tried to avoid talking about it
post-release as a result because
i just don't feel like anyone should
want to come to a person whose name is
in the credits for any kind of critical
coverage
it seems obvious to me but i realized
upon editing that i should add a note
here
i was always cool with just disclosing
my bias and talking about it before
release because
access to the information was restricted
when there's no other way for you to get
access to the game me choosing to limit
the sharing of information rather than
just disclosing my involvement
would be overall negative to players in
my opinion now that it's out there are
loads of people talking about it i don't
see a ton of value in me speaking about
it when every other person has the same
access to the information that i do and
i don't have anything to say that other
people haven't already said
other than this video which side note if
me making that disclosure makes you want
to click out of this video
please do i would just hope that you
also would have clicked out of every
video where i made the disclosure
six months ago i think they are very
important and i think we should take
them seriously but i digress
basically people who listened to the
extremely positive
consistently positive i mean everyone
was really saying the same stuff
previews of cyberpunk 2077 feel like
they were lied to
the very short summary of this video is
that people who
played cyberpunk 2077 early and spoke
about it did not lie
about anything there were no lies told
um for the most part and certainly in my
experience
a lot of these people were just very
excited like just as excited as the
general public seem to be everyone gets
caught up in the same height
and we're shown a very specific tailored
preview built
i can't speak to the reviews i did not
get an early review copy of the game
i did have two people come on my channel
to talk about that
but i did not have any input on that as
i didn't get a review copy so i
definitely can't speak to the review
scores
but what i played was essentially the
exact same as the gameplay videos that
released in 2018 and 2019. like
very very very very similar it was
actually just those two chunks of
gameplay sort of stitched together
if you saw how excited the internet was
about these gameplay videos when they
came out
imagine how excited i was to be playing
it and everyone else who covered it
that's pretty much what they played
it was mind-blowingly awesome and there
are still parts of cyberpunk that i
think are
very good just to be clear i do
generally like the game overall as
someone who is playing it on pc with the
3080 despite
recognizing there is room for
improvement but we did also stream it
directly from pcs in poland rather than
downloading the game ourselves
it was all very controlled and the main
point is that that is not unusual i did
have
four different people come on this
channel to talk about the preview to
make sure that it wasn't just my
coverage and there are a lot of
different angles
um and while i did play it in a very
linear way i essentially just played
those two bits and didn't really explore
the open world a tremendous amount we
did have people
uh on that stream talk about the more
open world sides of the game but you
know all of the preview impressions are
very similar
they're all very positive and they all
say very similar stuff they all
like the game it's actually just because
what we played all lines up we all
played the same thing
you know what i played did have pieces
missing the crafting was missing there
were cutscenes missing
plenty of things that we couldn't do and
loads of things that we couldn't speak
to and
now i sort of think that myself and
everyone else who has ever done a
preview and has not been more explicit
about
quite how they function uh has made a
mistake
on the same note every youtuber who is
telling you that anyone who liked the
game was paid or was reading a script is
also doing you a disservice because that
is
absolutely not the truth and i figured i
could explain this myself but i figured
it would be more useful
to speak to someone who has made preview
builds or worked on them or shipped them
and
you know has kind of become a bit of a
spokesperson for
developers in general in some cases so
cue interview i did with
uh dutch indie game dev from me can you
tell me what exactly
is a preview build or when you give a
preview
to press what are they actually playing
right
usually what happens is early on in
development
you you create this thing called a
vertical slice
right and this idea the idea of that is
that you take
a small fraction of the game and kind of
get it to the level where you want it to
be at the end and it's it's aspirational
right it's not
it's not real it's more of a thing you
use to
promote what you're trying to do to get
the team to understand what you're
trying to do it's sort of a
communication tool
more than anything else and a preview
build is usually more of a reflection of
that
it's separately built it's um
usually on a completely separate track
from the main development of the game
and it uses a lot of the systems you're
going to use
and obviously a lot of the render tech
you're going to use but it might be that
um you're using too many resources for
the final game or
a mechanic doesn't work out or an entire
sequence gets cut
or a level gets cut like it's it's the
idea of where you want to go
so one point of confusion that i
i see about this is would you say that a
preview
build of a game is the game or is it
kind of a separate thing entirely yeah i
think it's more of a separate like
it it depends obviously it depends on
the game it depends on the scope of the
game it depends on how far in
development the game is and then what
kind of things happen in development but
i think generally it's sort of a
separate thing entirely even on on
indie games that i've worked on um
very frequently the preview build is
something where you
put some of the best parts of the game
that you have
together and sometimes even create a few
things that
are going to be in there later hopefully
um
and sometimes you like you know you you
cheat a little bit you got some corners
to
to make a thing work right there because
you know you're gonna build it later
um sometimes it works out sometimes it
doesn't but
um i guess that's game development as a
whole is effectively
cheating right we're lying like the
building isn't real it's floating in a
blue box
of infinity and we just put a sky image
on it
and that's basically the gist of it a
preview or a demo is extremely subject
to change
and the bigger the game gets the more
likely it is to break
especially with an open world game um
even if it's
something really small say there's a
book at the beginning of the game
something that you add later that has
nothing to do with that book
could break that book could make it
function in a different way because
code is very fickle i almost feel a
little bit condescending being that
like specific about it because i know
it's common knowledge to a lot of people
who follow games but i i felt like it's
something that i should highlight
um because of some of the conversations
that i've had that it is clear that not
everyone necessarily knows this
this thing that maybe i take for granted
that everyone knows
where people have said but how could it
possibly be buggier six months later
than it was when you played it basically
the more of the game exists the more
bugs there are
uh and again the builds are also
separate but to give you more
information i asked romney about this
too so
how is it possible and this has you know
when i was a journalist what three years
ago now this did happen a number of
times that
um a preview build can have no bugs
but then the final release of a game
even in the same section that was seen
in the preview builds
can have a bunch of books how does that
happen well that mostly happens because
a preview built like that is its own
independent little part of the game
right so
they can really sort of lock in on just
how things work in that tiny section of
game
so you you make sure that things work
well
usually they're pretty controlled in how
and what you can do
you know what abilities the player has
at the start of the preview you know
what they can do where they're gonna go
you know how much time they have uh you
know where it's going to end so it's
it's a lot easier to get that perfectly
right
than say in an open world game where
there's 60 different ways to enter a
room
basically more video game more choice
more bugs that is one of the million
reasons that previews are often across
the board so positive
um but i do also think there is a
culture of people being more forgiving
with them because they know they are
works in progress
um and that it is an early build in the
case of cyberpunk what i played was
awesome
i really was it's also a lot of the
things that i was told
led into that um what the dev team was
saying was awesome and some of that
stuff did not make it into the final
game but yes to this point a preview
build is an early build it is massively
subject to change
and it is not the game for a review copy
yes it is effectively the game sans
occasionally a day one patch which
people are generally very explicit about
but a preview build is not the game that
is
not true it is misleading and a lot of
people clearly don't understand that and
that is
a coverage mistake i did also see it
make headlines when it came out that the
demos were faked and found it very odd
to see that making so much news when
every demo is faked every single one is
fake all of them 100 of them are fake
that is a
weird reductive way of phrasing it but
that isn't a new thing by any means
literally all of them
are fake our different builds are not
the game
all of them so now here's the part of
the video that i feel like people will
dislike most even though i'm sure
you know going against the the popular
narrative
will upset people regardless here still
feels worthwhile to make this video
while it does
seem like cyberpunk had more
discrepancies to the general public
uh from what the game said it was
earlier what previewers said versus what
it was when it came out
uh i don't believe that any of that was
intentional and when i say that i'm
speaking on a dev level
um not on a level of upper management or
higher ups i am speaking on on
the level of the developers who are the
people that i spoke to who led my demo
who i
interviewed i imagine that the demo that
i played and that everyone else played
was exactly what the game was intended
to be and planned to be
when it released i imagine everything
those devs said which is what all of the
media and youtube is reported on
um and all the subreddits covered and
all that stuff was intended to be in the
game and was consistent
with their vision which i think is the
same for no man's sky in most cases the
multiplayer thing throws me for a bit of
a loop there
some of that coverage was very off but
they believe what they said to be true
at the time
just as the people who previewed it did
uh the game just got bigger and bigger
and bigger and it got away from them
and i've been saying this since before
the game came out
just because the repeated delays and
something about the way they were doing
it
really concerned me not because of what
i played again what i played was rad
but i really wish they hadn't delayed
the game further i really i wanted that
even before december you know
it just felt like it shouldn't come out
and as a side note god it sucks to watch
people get mad whenever devs
delay games be pro game delay it will
give you better video games even if it
sucks
we want games to come out later if they
need more time and i know that that some
of the rhetoric surrounding that is like
well but they should know better
they shouldn't promise a release date if
they can't and i do have a video that i
just put up recently on this channel
where i talk about why sometimes they
have to do that i'll leave a link in the
description that's very specifically
about
why that happens and certainly why it
happened with
cd projekt red but when it comes to
announcing a release date when they know
the truth is like video games are really
hard to schedule time for
very very very hard you can say might be
done in six months and it could be two
years
because because they're so complicated
to make which is what's so cool about
our medium but also
screws people over where this kind of
conversation is concerned
now i do think some things are probably
going to change out of everything that
happened here especially like
specifically with cd projekt red and i
think some of these things are good and
some of them are bad i think one of the
things that is a pro and a negative
is that they probably won't talk about
their game in progress so openly
again i mean the same thing phoned them
with the witcher 3 um
the way the game looked before it came
out and then afterwards people were very
very critical of just that things
changed over the development cycle and i
think being one of the
most open game studios that i've ever
encountered which as someone who
really likes talking to developers and
learning about their processes
especially again now that i work at a
dev studio i'm like
so interested in what other people are
making i think that that's something
that they will probably learn to cut off
this is a positive for consumers because
it means that they won't
say things that don't end up in the game
which can be
taken as marketing even if it's just
kind of devs chatting about what they're
making
you're still saying that publicly where
an audience can hear it there is a
negative fish consumers they're like 1
000
over um from my perspective having a dev
studio of that scale that was so
unrestrained
like second to none unrestrained
everyone else is so much more locked
down by their pr departments
um was great but i think we'll probably
lose that they will probably be a lot
more controlled by pr across the board
and ultimately that is going to help a
lot of people and of course i really
hope
again a thing that i would have done
differently is that on the press side
which for me i would include both
traditional journalists and youtubers
people will be a lot more transparent
about what preview builds actually are
there's usually a note
on on a lot of the big sites saying like
no this is subject to change the preview
build
but it is nowhere near explicit enough
that has not been communicated
anywhere near to the extent that it
should have been and truthfully i don't
think there's actually
any way um that press really can know
if a demo is going to turn out different
to the final game i i actually don't
think anyone
who played cyberpunk early and reported
on it could have known
that anything would change from what
they were told and i don't see that
changing i just don't know how it could
change
um maybe someone in the industry can
figure that out but i don't really see
an obvious solution there other than to
be much more explicit
when saying temporary expectations this
preview could be inaccurate things could
change very significantly
i think it especially occurs for games
that have been in development for a
really long time i guess audiences also
really have to listen for that to work
um that's a part of it
i really don't feel like anyone listened
uh when i said i was biased about the
game
um because people seem to have just
forgotten every time that i said that
now like i wish people had had heard i
was saying that for a really good reason
i knew i was really excited about this
game and that i am still a fan of it
that hasn't changed despite recognizing
some of this stuff is really
anti-consumer which brings me to
one sort of final point i've always been
very pro-review
and i hope that audiences are a little
bit more pro review
about this now too i wrote a thing for
ign way way way back about how i thought
it was really anti-consumer
that bethesda wasn't giving reviewers um
more than one day
with any of their games so they
basically couldn't accurately tell their
audiences if there were bugs if there
were features missing that were reported
on
um i i think it it's a bad bad bad
policy
for the public to not give some people
early access
to a game and there are a lot of really
hostile comments in response to that uh
ultimately a lot of
shut up i don't need reviewers i make my
own decisions you don't deserve early
access to anything cry harder ign
and there has also been a recent
consistent rhetoric uh
that is along the lines of even
accepting games early
makes you a chill but from my
perspective if people had had
early access to the playstation 4 and
xbox one
copies of the game which i would hope
that the public would try to put
pressure on the publisher for
then people would have known that there
were massive issues
with those particular versions of the
game they can warn people that the
product they're about to buy is really
broken i think ign
gave the console versions of four i
definitely tweeted that out
felt like a thing that that people
should know um and
restricting early access to those things
from my perspective
is a really awful practice i immediately
assume it's shady if a publisher isn't
giving people early access to a game i
immediately think that there is
something wrong
and i hope that general gamers
are more open to that line of thinking
going forward i do also want to know
that i did from the start
literally the first video where i spoke
about this wasn't quite as explicit
there but
i said it in ign videos as well say that
there was no way that this game was
going to run on xbox one and ps4
inexcusable i've also repeatedly said
that i think it's 100
cdpr's fault and that that is
inexcusable and super anti-consumer i am
not in support of it at all
but i definitely did explicitly say that
on more than one account there's no way
it was ever going to run in closing to
surmise a preview build is a plan for
what a game is supposed to be
it isn't always possible and that's
usually because of higher ups because of
management because of people trying to
make the money because of the stock
market
rather than because of the dev team is
everyone who plays a game early and says
positive things paid off or lying to you
no obviously not i mean in the paid off
part that would be a massive lawsuit
that would be
a huge lawsuit that would currently be
under investigation if that were a thing
because it is
extremely illegal to pay someone to give
a positive opinion
alrighty that is it for me today
everyone i'm alana i will see you guys
next time